i will always be here
and i'm always yours
that is literally the nicest thing that
anybody's ever said to me the young and
the restless is getting ready for an
historic lgbtq plus wedding fan favorite
mariah played by cameron grimes proposed
to her girlfriend tessa played by kate
fairbanks
marking the first time that the series
has ever had a same-sex engagement the
actresses sat down to talk about filming
the momentous wedding scenes with e.t
candace it's a lot of pressure
but um honestly it was for us it was
just like another day at work um and
then you know kind of the the uh
enormity of it like hits you and you
realize you know what's uh
what is being taped is i mean it is it's
history tessa and mariah's story has
received a huge amount of support from
ynr fans who have affectionately dubbed
the on-screen couple taraya i mean it's
just such an honor honestly i mean i
feel like i say that a lot but it is
true yeah um just being able to
and you know i feel really lucky for
social media to be able to see what they
think
and to give us insights and or how they
feel about it their passion infers
us and our and and our performance so
whether they know it or not they have a
huge huge influence on on what we what
we do the stars also opened up about
what comes next for their characters
after the wedding bells stop ringing
it is a soap opera yeah happy
happy doesn't always you know it's kind
of the kiss of death yeah a little bit
but um
yeah that's exciting and i think it's
also just a part of being on a soap so
if we get the grace to be like every
other couple on this show i think both
of us would be very excited